en el vídeo pasado pudimos encontrar el
valor del área que se encuentra en estas
dos regiones esta área combinada la cual
corresponde al área de traslape entre
estos dos círculos y obtuvimos 9 p menos
18 todo eso sobre 8 lo que quiero
mostrarte en este vídeo es que puedes
usar una calculadora gráfica común y
corriente para obtener el mismo
resultado vamos a evaluar directamente
la integral definida veamos cómo se hace
esto y lo que voy a hacer lo puede ser
para coordenadas rectangulares las
coordenadas cartesianas usuales o
coordenadas polares pues lo único que
voy a hacer es evaluar la integral
definida así es que lo que queremos
hacer es evaluar 9 que multiplica a la
integral de 0 a pi cuartos de seno
cuadrado de teta de teta para esto
presionamos en la calculadora la tecla
de segundo y cálculo y elijo la opción
efe en int para calcular una integral
definida así es que vamos a usar esa
función y lo primero que hay que definir
es cuál es la función de la cual vamos a
tomar la integral definida y aquí vamos
a tomar la integral definida de seno de
hecho aquí voy a poner un paréntesis
vamos a tomar la integral definida de
seno y aquí puede usar cualquier
variable mientras sea consistente con
respecto a que estoy integrando
usualmente utilizo x pues hay un botón
de x suponemos que en este caso x éste
está así que seno de x al cuadrado en
vez de seno cuadrado de teta insisto en
que estamos usando x en lugar de teta y
ahora tenemos que especificar con
respecto a qué variable estamos
integrando en este caso es x si
hubiéramos puesto teta y tendríamos que
poner teta aquí también y ahora vamos a
poner los límites de integración y aquí
es importante que la calculadora se haya
puesto en modo de radiales en este caso
eso es algo que yo hice previamente así
es que la integral va de 0 a pi cuartos
de cero
y entre cuatro y cuartos y así obtenemos
que esto es igual a este número que
tenemos aquí que ahora necesitamos
multiplicar por 9 tomamos la respuesta
previa por 9 con tan sólo apretar la
tecla x obtiene la respuesta previa por
9 y obtenemos este número 1.284 29 vamos
a verificar que es el mismo valor que
obtuvimos cuando calculamos la integral
la mano analíticamente tenemos 9 y 9 y
menos 18
todo eso dividido dividido entre 8 y que
obtenemos obtenemos exactamente el mismo
valor en fin espero que esto te haya
convencido que se obtiene el mismo valor
de cualquier manera pero lo importante
es que viste cómo usar la calculadora
para evaluar integrales definidas lo
cual resulta sumamente útil cuando la
integral definida no se puede evaluar
analíticamente